alors on va faire du tour de table
cinéma qui a déjà roulé une pelle au
cinéma ce n'est pas tout le monde
arrêtez d'être arrêté d'être sale
arrêter d'être sale vous bat chaque fois
que la question des travaux où vous
n'avez pas volé leur nom au cinéma j'ai
la chance d'habiter dans le xvème à
paris oui des cinémas ya des seychelles
où il n'ya pas de siège pour couple a
deux ex en sang le lac ou grand entre
les deux du coup on peut s'en lasser à
regarder un film à deux comme ça du coup
regarde pas le film il faut y aller at
the way c'est le premier film que vous
avez vu la grande vadrouille dans le wat
dit la vérité ta ta ta déjà où les
palois n'ont soit c'était un de mes
premiers rangs car c'est au cinéma je
crois ouais pareil pour toi raphaël moi
c'est à dire la crêperie bah oui enfin
quand vous avez 13 14 ans vous aller au
ciné pour évidemment rouler des patins
parce qu'il fait nuit c'est plus facile
donc pas franchement été facile
13 mai que là je voulais des patins
c'est à toi même premier baiser je les
fais au cinéma 19 ans sait qu'un film
c'est alors c'était un film d'auteur
dans le cadre d'un festival à belfort
est vivant et une technique lorsque tu
es avec que ta copine c'est ben beau
tourner susurrer des mots doux à temps
devant débattu sur ares qui est
important de faire ça et là tu déplaces
les r30 à vous
et des successeurs du christ fusée mois
la veille pas et voilà on est dire l est
et d ça ça marche cette année et unsa
marché une fois alors vous non non moi
jamais jamais non honnêtement vous les
énoncés à wafa bien commencé of russia
mais non parce que je suis allé au
cinéma traite à 1,2110 est d'aller au
cinéma
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans et ouais ok je
m'appelle ailleurs l'attrait davout mois
le noir m'inspire donc j'ai tout fait au
cinéma franchement tout mais j'ai tout
fait au cinéma
pourquoi mais je sais pas ce que je peux
dire mais voilà j'ai été au cinéma
moquer qui a déjà fait qu'elle a fait
l'amour au cinéma bongouanou quoi qui a
déjà pris naissance dans une
station-service aussi c'est pas le
moment les sens ça c'est pas le moment
quoi vous bah oui bah oui je re quel
film all louisiane 3h07 à trois gains et
que sublime en louisiane j'ai été
sublime des plus grandes performances
trois séances de suite mais je vous jure
à suzuka des champs elysées sont
souviennent encore là non
[Applaudissements]
vous non mais non moi c'est avec avec
elle est restée au cinéma lumière avec
les frères lumière non non c'est au sein
effectivement embrassé avec alain qui
était mon fiancé à l'époque au cinéma
mais il avait extrêmement mal choisi
film parce que c'était la dernière femme
avec depardieu ou c'est l'histoire du
mec qui se tranche le sexe fait que
arriver ces salves a tout coupé a lui
aussi évoqué la voilà toute son
expérience c'est con parce qu'on avait
une bonne échappée comme ça quoi c'était
un festival de courts métrages
bah oui et tout vous c'est et good en
vous alors moi est très mignon et c'est
romantique parce que c'est mon premier
plan à trois
non mais non non non non non l
incroyable on n'en doute pas que du
sport à 10,97 je suis à montréal c'est
la sortie de titanic c'est un an avant
la france accentue tadic titanic 1 à
titanic 3 yann titanic quoi titanic a
nuancé malama salle quand même que c'est
ouf
tandis que les gars 20 ans vous aviez 23
vous allez vas-y vas-y s'était baladé au
canada fait parfois attendre deux ou
trois séances pour y aller donc j'y vais
je m'installe on est comme ça il ya une
personne qui vient s'installer à côté de
moi parce que force à vous prenez ma
connaissance il a deux que j'ai jamais
vue de ma vie et pendant le film
certainement il a eu peur à ce qui m'a
pris pour kate ou quoi quand même c'est
de cet échange filmé il me prend la main
comme ça non ça c'est la cuisse a droit
la connais je vous connais suis pas la
personne elle aussi des mâles vous prend
la main ils étaient pas moche hein hein
mais je crois pas je suis là ça commence
par la cuisse maja machin on se regarde
on regarde il a voulu dire c'est pas ma
cuisse
non on trouve comme suit comme si un
petit peu mignon je lui dis bah voilà ce
que ça te dit de pas tu es célibataire
comateux prendre un verre ne suis pas
célibataire monde est venu à douillet
pas de place
mon mec est au deuxième rang non mais
oui oui les fidèles en tout cas du cros
sort du film on retrouve son mec qui me
présente mathieu ans s'est rendu pendant
titanic
on est parti ensemble et la suisse elle
sera en deuxième partie de soirée je
vous raconterai pas ce que la société
plus coquine mais oui mais je donne mon
premier plan à léo c'est chaud quand
même vous donne ça rappellera que jamais
lui aussi aller au cinéma et vous moi
j'ai et que des plans à deux mois je
voulais tu vives béton dans la boum d'or
j'ai tout vécu comme elle effectivement
mon premier baiser ou mouillé ça avec
salive appuyé soutenu c'était devant la
boum 2 mois je vais casser l'ambiance
moi quand je paye le cinéma 10 euros les
pop corn
le film vient de l'autre
moi je rejoins nolwenn et delphine je
pense que c'est les premiers amours on
se cache dans le noir à la hausse comme
ça c'est cool mais après on a plus
besoin fut donc fait que voulaient les
démarches en fait dans bien pourquoi
vous parlez du titanic alors pour mis à
dos alors je vous dire ne pas dire pas
de baiser rien déchets jamais fait
l'amour au cinéma j'ai jamais fait
l'amour tout court
voilà deux cris toi comme tu vas pas
souvent on a tendance à faire vous avez
le coup ça c'est les rôles où ça est ce
que ces remous salalah beach
[Applaudissements]